WILLIAM: It's my honor
to welcome Zia Ahmed.
Zia is a Lyft driver and the
compiler of "Lyft Me Up San
Francisco."
So Zia, in your own words, what
is "Lyft Me Up San Francisco"?
ZIA AHMED: Well, to
start with, thank
you very much for having me.
A big shout out to William, who
not only set this entire thing
up, invited all of
you and everything,
I think it's been
super well done.
So thank you for having me.
Yeah, absolutely.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you.
So yeah, the
interesting little story
is that I'm a Lyft
driver, and as I
drive around San
Francisco, I like
to ask my current
passengers to leave
my next passenger a message.
I took those messages, which
I was compiling in this book,
I put them in another
book, and I published it.
Would you like to
hear some of them?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ZIA AHMED: Yeah.
Excellent.
Because if you didn't, then I
don't know what we would do.
So a couple interesting
messages that I
want to jump into really
quickly and also share
some stories of the different
type of things that happen
while you're kind of
driving, when you're seeing
the city, when you're out
there contracting with people
and just what happens when you
have a little conversation--
some funny things-- or just
some very touching things
that I've learned
or seen as well.
So someone once
wrote, "in May 2012
my apartment and everything
I own burned down.
Yesterday I moved back
with the same roommates.
Everyone survived,
life went on, and we've
made every day count since."
So I think that's a
pretty interesting message
that a person would
actually leave in a book
where they're anonymously
asked to write something down.
What do you think?
WILLIAM: Yeah, agree.
Just so you guys
know, Zia happens
to have a near photographic
memory of all of passengers.
So I'm curious who left
it, what was the ride like?
Maybe not the
to-from, but tell me
a little bit about the
context behind that message.
ZIA AHMED: Yeah, for sure.
I think it was a
Sunday afternoon.
We were driving
towards-- we were
crossing Zeitgeist, If you're
familiar with San Francisco,
yeah?
Zeitgeist.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
WILLIAM: Some nods in there.
ZIA AHMED: There it is.
So that's like around
14th and Valencia,
and the building that's being
referred to here that burned
down in 2012 was the building
right opposite to that
with that little grocery store.
So kind of an interesting
story that this person came
and dropped, and
that's most of what
I can remember from that day.
WILLIAM: Well, that's
already quite a bit.
So do you have another maybe
less serious, more serious,
less insightful,
more insightful?
ZIA AHMED: Absolutely.
There are plenty of them,
plenty of interesting stories.
Let me actually
put this down here.
Plenty of interesting
stories, but some
of the ones that
really meant something
to me, some of them
that really touched
for some reason or the
other, are the ones
that I really want to share.
So this is an interesting one.
Now, the story is that I read
this-- when the book came out
in early September, I was trying
to get the word out and share
it with the rides that I had.
I didn't exactly know
how, so I was just
kind of putting these
little markers on it
and having random
people read it.
So this message says,
"Giant sequoias need fire
in order to reproduce at all.
Although a field of
burning trees after a fire
may look tragic, it's
actually hopeful.
If you've had a fire
in your life recently,
breathe and embrace it.
The seedlings will come soon."
And when that person read
that, he actually broke down,
started crying.
And this guy was
visiting from Tahoe.
He's visiting his
significant other
who lives in Outer Mission.
He starts crying in my car.
Now, I didn't want
that to happen.
That's not exactly what I was
hoping the reaction would be,
but it meant something
to him so much,
and it deeply touched him,
that he bought two books
and paid me $60 for it instead
of the actual average price.
So I feel like it's a very
impactful kind of story that
happened, and it showed
me the meaning of what
this type of connection, whether
it's writing it down or reading
it from somebody else,
could be really meaningful.
WILLIAM: Yeah, absolutely.
And do you have maybe a
particularly funny one?
Obviously humor
depends on the person,
but do you have something that
you look at that kind of makes
you chuckle every
time you read it?
ZIA AHMED: That's a very
good question actually,
and I'm glad you
did point that out.
This I want to say it was
probably a week night,
and a Wednesday, Thursday
I was driving a couple
from the Mission to
the Fillmore District.
And what happened was
the guy gets up front
and the girl gets in the back,
and they wrote a message,
and the situation is
going to add a little bit
more fascinating context, right?
So is says over here, "put
yourself out of your comfort
zone, like butt stuff,
and remember you win some
and you lose some."
And what happens is
that they actually
forgot a bag in the car, and
that bag is lying right there.
You want to go check it
out and see what's in it?
WILLIAM: I have no
idea what is in this.
Let me see what.
I feel like I'm about to
get in trouble with this.
Oh, good.
Oh, goodness.
We've got some toys here.
We have--
ZIA AHMED: Some fascinating
toys such as this.
WILLIAM: Not returned.
ZIA AHMED: And the idea
is that it's really
like-- what happened
after that is what
I wanted to kind
of also highlight,
is that they left
that in the car.
I didn't know it.
So the next person
gets in the car,
and she's like, oh, dude
there's a bag over here.
I'm like, oh no.
I have to return this
to whoever it is,
because these are valuables.
They're going to
probably call me,
email me, something like that.
And she reaches in the bag,
and she pulls that out.
And she's like, you
staged this, didn't you?
I'm like, what?
How did you even-- that is the
last thing that was on my mind,
but thank you for highlighting
that that would've
been an interesting story.
WILLIAM: So you
never returned that?
It never made its way back.
ZIA AHMED: Yeah.
I was also thinking-- so nobody
ever called back to get it.
Nobody left an email,
because those are generally
the ways in the app that
you can get something back.
Plenty of cell phones have been
left, plenty of wallets, keys,
like you name it, but nobody
called to get this back.
And I'm wondering
what would they say?
What would they say?
WILLIAM: That's true.
ZIA AHMED: So kind of
fascinating stories like that.
Those are the kind of
stories and situations
that have been happening.
And some of these messages can
get really interesting as well,
really touching stories
about individuals
and just what's
happening in their life.
Another example that I
always really like telling,
because people get really
insightful about their lives,
is that "we met at a dive bar,
like a really terrible one,
and we're getting
married next year.
Just proves that any
shit can happen."
And it's fascinating
that when they
have an opportunity or
an outlet like this,
that they just drop
something about their life,
and it was a super cute couple.
They were really excited.
I think I was driving them
around SoMa or mid-market,
some area like that.
And they kind of shared
that with us in the book.
So I think it was a
really nice passage.
WILLIAM: Absolutely.
So a wide variety of
stories, of passengers--
ZIA AHMED: An entire range--
WILLIAM: --cross-section
of the city.
ZIA AHMED: --an entire
range of profound,
profanity, all sorts of humor.
And I also think that not
only is it the message,
but I feel like people
love being part of this
and participating in it as well.
So they feel like they're
either part of something
a little bit bigger, or
they're getting an opportunity
to share something
to, in their opinion,
make life perhaps a little
bit better for someone.
You know what I mean?
WILLIAM: Interesting.
Interesting.
So we've heard a
bit about the book,
but I'm curious to learn about
the man behind the book--
ZIA AHMED: Uh-oh.
WILLIAM: --the man behind
the steering wheel.
So can you tell us a
little about your life
and how you wound
up in San Francisco?
ZIA AHMED: Sure, for sure.
So I have a background
in tech, and I
have a background in
marketing, media, broadcasting,
technology, advertising,
all sorts of weird things--
completely unrelated
all of them--
and I was an account
manager basically
at an advertising
company, and then
I started working
in a tech company
when I came to San Francisco.
And I came with
the entire dream.
I drank the Koolaid.
It was wonderful.
And I started working at a
start up called CrowdFlower.
I do have a couple of my friends
over here from there today.
There they are.
And after a few months
of me working over there,
not only did I
feel a little like,
OK, there's something not
right, I don't know what it is,
but I'm not feeling it,
and the balance statement,
the balance sheet of the
company, felt the same way.
It was an interesting
time for the company
as well, because we were
scaling up really fast,
and it didn't really work out.
So there was a massive
layoff over there,
and I was one of them.
That's kind of the story
before the story starts.
WILLIAM: Sure.
Absolutely.
And I know that you have,
not only that surprise,
but another surprise
coming for our audience.
Do you want to talk about that?
ZIA AHMED: Absolutely.
So the interesting
thing is that one
of the reasons why I feel
this worked with so many
and resonated with
so many people
is that there was an element
of surprise over here.
And I wanted to recreate
that surprise with you
folks over here right now.
So what I want you to do-- what
I want Will to actually do over
here-- if you could quickly hand
out one of those to everybody.
And what I've done is
for the past two weeks
or three weeks since I was
trying to sort this out
with William, is I was
asking my passengers
to leave a message for
somebody at Google.
Absolutely.
So go ahead and open it up.
Read the message that's
written, and I have no idea
what's in there, by the way.
WILLIAM: And I didn't
screen this, so if it's--
AUDIENCE: No anthrax, I hope.
WILLIAM: No.
ZIA AHMED: So I think
if we grab the mic,
I want to listen to some of
the ones that people left.
WILLIAM: Yeah.
Let's read them out.
I think the mic is on now.
We can get rid of "National
Geographic" behind us
at the same time.
ZIA AHMED: Is this on?
WILLIAM: Yes, I
do believe it is.
ZIA AHMED: So a little
bit more about it,
this is kind of
similar to the paper
that I was using
in the actual book
where I was gathering
these messages,
and it's a handmade
paper, with one side
is a message from what
my passenger wrote,
and the other side is
a message that I wrote.
You'll obviously be able
to tell which one's which.
But if we can have
a volunteer, please.
Anybody want to?
All right.
AUDIENCE: "Thanks
Google for making my job
easier with all your
marketing platforms.
Smiley face."
ZIA AHMED: The
marketing platform.
People love that.
What do we have here?
AUDIENCE: We have a
political one here.
"Hey, Google, I feel
like as a company
you have very similar
characteristics
to those of the Middle
East, Iran in particular.
Are you trying to
take over the world?
Why the robots?
Are you sending them to war?
Sincerely, Cheri."
ZIA AHMED: What
was the last one?
AUDIENCE: Are you
sending them to war?
Why the robots?
Are you sending them to war?
ZIA AHMED: That
actually is something
you may want to think about.
AUDIENCE: That's a good idea.
ZIA AHMED: Of course it is.
Sorry, who is it?
Was it Tyler?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I got a good one.
It says, "Google
Docs is the shit.
Has saved my schooling
and some cash."
And then he also writes, "turn
it back to the old logo."
Old logo.
ZIA AHMED: I feel that
happened a few times.
Anybody else?
Would you like to
share what you got?
AUDIENCE: "Google, I
love Google Wallet.
I use it for work.
Every day gives this
guy what he wants."
ZIA AHMED: Interesting.
Some other?
One more?
There you go.
AUDIENCE: I'm a contractor.
So I feel OK saying this.
I also disagree with the person.
"I called this Lyft this morning
because Google Maps, combined
with public
transportation, is trying
to make my life as
complicated as possible.
You should work on that."
I love Google Maps.
I just want to point out.
ZIA AHMED: Thank you.
Very cool.
I want to do one or two more.
Has anybody-- all
right, we got one.
Then you, because I'll
come across the room.
AUDIENCE: I got, "I use
Google Docs to stash my nudies
and drug orders.
I've never thought about Google
so long and hard before."
ZIA AHMED: Right?
So broadly speaking--
WILLIAM: Standard use case.
ZIA AHMED: --just
so you know, this
is what to expect from the book,
on a broad San Francisco level.
AUDIENCE: "Dear Google,
don't get me wrong.
You have a great
product, but aside
from feeding your employees
good quality organic foods,
please consider feeding the
poor and homeless at least
a few times a month.
I know you are good for it.
Go humanity.
Love, SF native."
ZIA AHMED: I love it.
So a couple of examples.
Anybody else, or do
you want to-- OK.
Sweet.
So that's kind of what
the experience was
of receiving something
completely out of the blue,
not expecting it.
We've all done it
thousands of times,
but this time was slightly
a little different.
WILLIAM: So you're
living in San Francisco,
and you're working in tech, and
then you mentioned this layoff.
So where did this
project sprout from?
ZIA AHMED: Right, for sure.
So for me, not
only have I always
wanted to have an
entrepreneurial kind
of experience,
but the idea was I
wanted to stay in San Francisco.
The big idea was that after
the story-- kind of the plot
thickened, and the
company didn't work out--
what I wanted to do was I wanted
to figure out what I should do,
what I would enjoy
doing and stay longer.
I started driving
for Lyft because I
was meeting a lot of
fascinating people,
a lot of really
interesting stories
were happening, getting to meet
a range of different people
throughout the city,
some fun experiences.
And I really didn't know
where this was going to lead,
but what I always felt was
that, as much as people enjoyed
talking about the sense of
community, after that one ride,
it really was over, and I
wanted to somehow capture that.
I wanted to not
only capture that,
but I also wanted to
connect with the person.
Like what could I ask him
or what could I tell him
that would allow this
to be a little bit more
than just a ride from
point A to point B,
which is when I started asking
them to write this down.
Does that makes sense?
WILLIAM: Yeah, absolutely.
And I know this is
something that we've
talked about in the past, and I
think that it's so natural, so
easy for someone to say, oh,
you've met thousands of people,
that you've read through
thousands of notes, which are
your favorite passages and why?
ZIA AHMED: That's an
interesting point.
So I've been
collecting actually I
want to say on the range of
about 3,000 to 4,000 messages
over the past one year.
And the ones that
I put in this book
actually meant
something to me somehow.
Now, either it was sharing
something insightful
about the person
themselves or it
was talking about
somewhere fascinating to go
in the city, some experience
that I should have
which I haven't had previously.
Quite literally, anything
that spoke to me.
Either it was something
about themselves,
something that spoke
to me, something
I could learn from what
they were talking about,
and if the person
was good looking.
So that was also an
important factor.
WILLIAM: Factor in the specs.
It factors in to what
makes it into the book.
So what are some, I guess,
takeaway themes from the book?
There are a lot of topics.
So we have sex, we have
technology, we have culture,
we have love.
But what are some of the themes
that really unify and tie
together, not only the
snippets that made it
into the compilation, but that
made it into the leather-bound
notebooks--
ZIA AHMED: Yeah
WILLIAM: --all together.
ZIA AHMED: So I was kind
of actually asking people,
like I wanted to
broadly ask them
to leave something which would
reveal a little something
about themselves.
I'm trying to guide them to be
able to speak about something
that they wanted to
share with somebody else.
It could be something
completely anonymous,
something could be a secret, it
could be something fascinating.
And I felt that a
lot of people were
giving certain thoughts, like
there were many cliches that I
got, but I also felt like
one of the interesting themes
that I noted, or
lack of themes, was
a lack of theme of the
spirituality element
or the idea of being
connected to something,
an element of that.
I felt that that was kind of
fascinating that I noticed.
WILLIAM: So as a
spiritual person,
that kind of surprises me.
Why do you think that is?
Why do you think
there was a lack
of spiritual or religious
overtones in the messages?
ZIA AHMED: You know, it could've
been one of the reasons,
because I was kind
of controlling
the flow of the
conversation in that car.
But broadly speaking,
I'm not really sure
why that wasn't there, but it is
something that I thought about.
WILLIAM: Sure.
Sure.
And related to
that point, I think
that the difficulty in compiling
a book, not that I've ever
compiled anything
that I know of,
is that you run
the risk of losing
your voice in the process.
So how do you maintain
artistic creativity and control
and find your voice
and leave your message
when you are
interacting and working
with messages of others?
ZIA AHMED: That part
of it, I was thinking
that I wanted to focus on not
only things that were happening
throughout what we were exposed
to in the form of the media
or anywhere else, but
whatever was going
on in the present at that time.
For example, when
the Pope was visiting
or when Donald Trump
was in the news.
These were conversations that
I was having with these people,
and that's what the
result was coming to.
So I was trying to
influence them to write
something a little fascinating.
That's also one of
the interesting things
that we're working for the
future of this project as well.
WILLIAM: So how do
you coach passengers?
So I rode with Zia
many months ago,
and I don't really remember the
exact way that you-- I think it
was something about a surprise
in the glove compartment, which
had me a bit worried.
ZIA AHMED: So from my--
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM: This is supposed
to be surprising first,
and so how do you guide that?
How do you let them know,
how do you guide them
through this process?
ZIA AHMED: So to start with, I
like to qualify my passenger.
I like to have a
conversation with them,
and I want to see what's up.
Like do I want this person
to be part of my project,
because it's all about me.
WILLIAM: So what you
do to the person who
sits in the backseat,
puts on the headphones,
takes the phone out.
ZIA AHMED: So first of all,
I try to get their attention,
because this is just an
approach to get their attention,
get them out of their phone,
get them out of that space.
Everyone's on their
phone all the time,
and I wanted to make a
social situation where
we're sitting in a car for 10
minutes, 12 minutes, and let's
interact with each other.
So from there, I would just
try and get their attention.
If I get their
attention, well and good.
Then that means we can
go a little bit further.
If not, then you
have to let it go.
But the idea is that
if they're fascinating,
if they have something that
kind of captures my imagination,
then I ask them go ahead and
open up the glove compartment,
because I have something
a little fascinating.
And that's how I shared it
with you too, I believe?
WILLIAM: Yes, yes.
So they open the
glove compartment,
and then I think
at that point, you
have a lot of
influence and control
over what they put down.
The next sentences
will really dictate
what they think about and then
what they commit to paper.
So do you try to introduce
a little bit of bias,
or do you really
say, hey, it's yours.
Do whatever you want.
ZIA AHMED: I like to
call them guidelines,
and those guidelines
are very broad.
They're very open
ended, but I also
feel that a lot of people,
that for some reason,
it adds pressure or it
starts to trouble people
when I introduce these
broad guidelines.
And the guidelines
are very simple.
No lyrics, no
quotes, no cliches,
because cliches are useless
and lyrics I can't publish.
Right?
WILLIAM: True, right.
ZIA AHMED: And the idea
is to leave something
to the next person
about who you are
or a little something
that you'd like to share,
broadly speaking.
After that, it's just a matter
of limiting the amount space
that you use, because those
diaries are beautiful,
and I hate wastage.
So I don't want
people to waste space,
and that's basically-- those
are the broad guidelines that I
give.
And from there, what they
write might be influenced
by the conversation I had prior
to sharing the diary with them.
Does that make sense?
WILLIAM: Yeah, absolutely.
So for those in the audience
considering starting a company,
myself included, what was it
like to be simultaneously kind
of the entrepreneur/CEO of
your Camry and this project?
ZIA AHMED: I'm glad put
it in the same category
as entrepreneurship, but I
did self publish the book,
so it's been actually a
very fascinating journey
from that angle as well.
So it's not only a
matter of the content
that I was trying to
influence and gather
but the self publishing route
is also a very fascinating one,
which I feel that I
speak to a lot of people,
and they're always
telling me, hey dude,
I want to publish a book too.
I want to self publish the book.
What's the process?
What's the route?
And really, for
me, it was I wanted
to do what I feel a lot of
people do, which is the agent,
the publisher, figuring
out, taking that route.
That route is a complete
myth, and it doesn't work, OK?
At least, in my humble opinion.
What I did was for the first
quarter of this project,
I was looking for an agent.
That didn't work out, so I was
going to publishers directly,
and they were giving me
feedback like find an agent,
or they're telling me things
like the amount of time
it takes to get from us to a
bookshelf is about three years.
And that's just
something that would
make the information outdated.
It wouldn't be a
fascinating project.
There were so many reasons
for me not to do that.
So I basically went on
Thumbtack and Craigslist,
found a team of
people, figured out
how we could break down
every single process.
I found people to be
part of that-- an art
director, a production
manager, an editor, all
of those elements, they're
all listed over here as well,
the My Team.
So I actually wanted to
take this opportunity
to give a shout out to them.
So Sam James Levine,
the Creative Director.
The editor was Marc Capobianco.
The Production Manager was
Hillary Savage, and the person
who is currently running
the social media,
if you guys do go on Facebook,
Twitter, any of these things,
Ashley Ryon is who's running
the social media wing of it.
And a buddy of mine,
funder, and childhood friend
who kind of supported the
project, Hasan [? Sufi. ?]
None of those guys
are here right now,
but they were all
part of this project,
and they played a pretty vital
role somehow or the other.
WILLIAM: What obstacles
did you overcome going down
the self publishing track?
ZIA AHMED: For sure.
It was figuring out--
managing a team.
Because I wasn't just
sending the right amount
of instructions to
the right person,
working with them
collaboratively,
and then kind of coming
out with a product which
suits my requirements, which I
wanted to put my name behind,
and something that I
feel is a work of art.
It's something that I feel a
lot of other people appreciate,
and I hope you guys do.
And also to kind of
start something, not just
start a company--
which I technically
had to register a company
to self publish it--
but also to try and
start a movement.
I feel that over the past
six, eight months when
this project got a little bit
of visibility in the media,
a lot of other drivers
from across the country
have actually come
out to me and wanted
to reach out for either
doing something similar
or reaching out
about other ideas
that we could potentially
collaborate on.
In fact, we have one right now
in the crowd too, so Grant.
Yeah, he is another
one of the Lyft drivers
who is running a very
fascinating documentary
project as well.
So if this creates enough
excitement for other people
to start doing
their own thing, I
think that's a
pretty good start.
WILLIAM: Yeah, so it ties
into my next question.
Where is this project headed?
What's next?
ZIA AHMED: So there are
different elements and angles
that I want to take
in this project.
So not only is it the
natural progression
of making a Volume 2 or finding
other drivers to get it--
and if you are a driver,
please do reach out.
The project is, again,
of course called
"Lyft Me Up San
Francisco," and I'm
looking for other
people who would
be interested in
compiling these messages.
Because one of the
fun things would
be to see what responses
people would leave if they were
influenced by somebody else.
So still leave it
broad and open,
but if there was another
influence behind this,
perhaps it'll be different.
And I want to see what
that would look like.
So that's one of the directions
that I do want to take.
So potentially in the
form of a Volume 2.
I don't know when
that's going to be.
That's probably going to be
after a lot of people buy this.
So please buy it, OK?
That's very important for a
very tiny, very small, start up.
So please be part
of the project.
It would be great
if you supported it.
Even if it's just telling
somebody about it,
not just getting it,
but Facebook, Twitter,
all those things actually work.
WILLIAM: So Volume 2 will
be the Google edition.
Is that fair to say?
ZIA AHMED: I'm so down.
Like let's talk about that.
Bring them to the table.
I'd love to get more
feedback for you guys.
And what's also interesting
is that-- I've been doing this
for about a year now, and when
the word started getting out
and people started to know that
somebody was doing something
like this, a lot of people
would get in the car and say,
hey, I've heard about this.
So they would also
come with something
in the back their mind,
thinking that, oh, I'm
going to write so and so.
They would have actually
already thought about it.
If they had seen
their friend, if they
would have heard their
friend talk about it,
or they would come into the
car and they would be like,
oh I know this.
I'm going to write
something potentially
a little bit different.
WILLIAM: In the book--
ZIA AHMED: Yes, in the book.
WILLIAM: --knowing that
their friends may--
ZIA AHMED: Yes.
WILLIAM: OK.
ZIA AHMED: Exactly.
WILLIAM: Interesting.
ZIA AHMED: And this way, if
we could get more people,
maybe that'll be an interesting
thing to observe as well.
WILLIAM: Sure.
ZIA AHMED: But I would
love to have a whole Google
kind of project.
Anybody else out
there as well, that
would be really fun to work
on, and we can find out
whatever your objectives,
criteria, requirements are,
and then we can sort it out.
WILLIAM: Yeah, the
voice of the people.
ZIA AHMED: Absolutely.
WILLIAM: So at this point
when someone gets in your car,
and I know I
actually met someone
at a party a couple weeks
ago who had ridden with you,
and I thought it was
a small world thing,
but do people kind of know now?
Oh, you're the--
I've heard about you.
You're the--
ZIA AHMED: It doesn't
happen that often.
WILLIAM: --Lyft driver.
ZIA AHMED: It
happens probably, I
want to say once-- let's
say twice or thrice a month.
So that's still better
than not, right?
I like that.
It's kind of--
WILLIAM: It's catching on.
ZIA AHMED: It is.
I want to go back to like
the future of the project
and where we're
going to take this.
So not only do I want
to go ahead and work
on potentially a
second volume of this,
but I want to expand
it in other directions
as well in the form
of a mini web series.
I think that every
decade has had
a very popular and successful
television show about this,
and I wanted to start
at least from the web
and create a tiny web series
about these little stories.
And it's not just these
stories, but there
are stories from across
the country and thousands
of drivers and millions of
rides that we can actually
take, put them
together and start
a tiny little kind
of sharing thing
to build community, to develop
empathy, understand each other,
and film that.
It would kind of interesting.
So that's one of the angles that
I want to do for the future.
Another very interesting angle
is the whole app version of it.
We were thinking about
gamifying this process or kind
of thinking about how we
could take this from this
to a process in your phone.
We don't have the
solution for these things
yet to capture everything,
but that is something
that we're working on.
One of my team members is
over here right now as well
that hopefully will work on.
WILLIAM: Perfect.
Great.
And I know, speaking
of the web series,
I know that you had a video.
ZIA AHMED: Yeah.
WILLIAM: Would you
like to share it now?
ZIA AHMED: Absolutely.
WILLIAM: I'm going to do that.
ZIA AHMED: So one of the
interesting things in the book,
kind of a little
world, is that people
are making book trailers.
So recently we shot a
book trailer as well,
and we're trying to
get the word out there
and trying to get other people
to understand the project
and get this idea
out there as well.
That's what we're going to
hopefully show right now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-I love my boyfriend,
but he sucks at sex.
-Don't cook bacon naked.
-Have as many one-night
stands as possible.
Never get brunch the next day.
Just wear a condom.
-San Francisco is like James
Franco's Instagram and Kanye
West's Twitter account.
You're always like WTF?
-In May 2012, my apartment and
everything I owned burned down.
Everyone survived.
Life went on, and we have
made every day count since.
Be thankful for life.
-I hit a guy with a car when
I was 16, and I didn't stop.
I think about it every day.
-I look at vaginas for a living.
What do you do?
-Today someone told me, you made
me smile, you made me laugh,
you made dream.
I think that was the best
compliment I've ever received.
This journal made me
laugh, smile, and dream.
Thank you.
My name is Zia, and I
started this project,
"Lyft Me Up San Francisco,"
and that kind of gives you
the idea of what it's about.
[END PLAYBACK]
WILLIAM: All right, thank you.
ZIA AHMED: That was it.
[APPLAUSE]
So a quick minute
and a half, I want
to say, of-- under a
minute and a half trailer.
This is something that
we're working on as well,
and that's kind of where I'm
taking this-- the direction
that we're taking.
WILLIAM: Perfect.
Great.
And I know that as part
of launching a book,
you have to build
this, build the buzz,
so where did you start,
and what kind of led you
to where you are now?
How did you get
the ball rolling?
ZIA AHMED: I think from a
visibility and awareness
point of view?
WILLIAM: Sure, yeah.
ZIA AHMED: So a lot
of people-- it's
been pretty fascinating
that a lot of people
during my ride who were either
writers for other publications,
I met a lot of them, and
that's where they're like, hey,
this a great story.
Let's cover it.
So I've had several people--
I've had the "Huffington Post"
cover it.
They were the first people
that actually got in the car,
and the guy loved it.
Andrew his name was,
and he totally loved it,
and he's like, all right,
we're going to cover this.
The next day, there
was a story out there.
I'm like, this is great.
We also had a lot
of-- KCBS covered it.
There's some neat
coverage over there.
And it's just been really people
who are getting in the car
and really liking it,
such as yourself as well.
So a big shout out and thank
you again to everybody who's
been supporting this project.
It's been super helpful,
and there was no other way.
It's been a very organic
growth kind of a process
that people who are
experiencing it,
they like it so much
that they're actually
word of mouth pushing it
forward, which is always
the best way to cover something
or gain movement and traction.
WILLIAM: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And with this web
series, I know that there
was a show you were telling
me about in the '90s which
had a taxicab confessional
or something, which
had a taxi driver and a camera
and just passengers caught
in a candid moment.
So what do you kind of foresee
your potential web series
looking like, and what
would the format be?
ZIA AHMED: Absolutely.
Every decade has had
an interesting kind
of transportation
show, and this is
the natural logical
progression of that.
And that's what we're trying
to do as well through capturing
these little stories
and creating characters
out of them.
So what I want to do and what
we're looking for right now
is people who can help
develop these characters.
And I want to create a mini web
series like "High Maintenance."
Are you guys familiar with that?
Have you guys ever heard of it?
So it was this interesting
show about a weed delivery
guy in Brooklyn.
The show was called
"High Maintenance."
It was actually brilliant.
It started like 2000--
seriously-- 2011,
and what it was about it
was it was about the story
was actually building
characters around the people
that the weed delivery
guy was interacting with.
So it wasn't about him.
It wasn't about his story.
It was about all
the other characters
that you come across.
They were tied together
by the delivery guy,
and that's kind of
the story of that,
and I want to build on that as
well but from a transportation
point of view, although
that's a very raw idea.
We're still trying to
find and fine tune that.
So there will probably
be several experiments
that we do before we
find the right one.
But that's, again, when you
launch any product or any start
up or any company
like that, you have
to kind of see what
the project looks like,
what resonates well with people,
and then build on that too.
WILLIAM: Absolutely.
And this is an
unrelated question to,
but I'm curious to
get your insight,
because you mentioned seeing
this cross-section of society.
Do you agree that San
Francisco is changing,
and where do you
think it's headed,
and are you excited about
that direction overall,
based on just the wide variety
of people that you interact
with and meet on a daily basis?
ZIA AHMED: So it's
definitely changing.
I think that there could
be a few-- because there's
a lot of the reality is that
a lot of people are unhappy,
and that is slightly
unfortunate, especially
because of the diversity,
the disparity perhaps,
and that we all
know about and see.
And I think somebody
pointed it out
as well in one of
their messages.
But I do feel that
there is more that
can be done from
everybody's side,
even if it's a little
project such as this, which
is to build community,
develop empathy,
capture these different ideas
from across town, and then
showcase that, it becomes
like the voice of the people.
And that's kind of what I'm
trying to achieve with this
and not just get one particular
person's point of view
or opinion but a broad range
of different types of people.
WILLIAM: Perfect.
I think that's a
great note to end on.
So if there are any
audience questions,
I think we could
entertain those now.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
ZIA AHMED: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
AUDIENCE: We haven't talked
about the company at all.
Does the company know
about this project?
What is the company
doing with it?
I like it.
WILLIAM: Somewhat intentional.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So probably intentional,
but can we talk about it?
ZIA AHMED: Yeah.
Let's talk about it.
What do you want to know?
So they find the idea
kind of fascinating.
They are interested,
and I have been
trying to reach
out to them, trying
to get-- I have gotten
their attention,
but I feel that it's still very
young for not only them to come
on board and work with me
the way I want them to,
but I do feel that
this is something
that we will eventually
reach in the future.
And they've got
some other-- they're
working on some incredible
other branding strategies.
For example,
billboards and wrapping
buses in their corporate colors.
So let's see when they decide
that this is a good idea.
AUDIENCE: So have you
taken any measures
to make sure people
aren't copying your idea?
Because I can imagine
other drivers, specifically
people from the other
company that's not Lyft--
WILLIAM: What company
would that be?
Sidecar.
Sidecar is the company.
AUDIENCE: --could think
this is a great idea too
and maybe want to copy you?
ZIA AHMED: Yeah.
I'm totally down for other
people doing this as well.
I want other people to
come on board in all forms.
Why do we need to limit this?
I don't want this just
to be about myself.
I want everybody to do it.
I want you to create
whatever version of this
you want it to be.
It'll be fun to see the other
directions that people take.
I don't want it to
just be about myself.
But I'm more than happy
to work with whoever
wants to, whether
it's the other company
or it's the other one
or whoever or wherever.
We can always work together
on fascinating solutions,
but I don't want to
limit this to just me.
And I want other people
to be part of it,
from capturing a
message point of view,
from whether they want
to do, I don't know,
however they see it.
AUDIENCE: I just
have a question.
Did you get only
text or also drawings
and if you had drawing as
well, did the message differ
from the text?
Like are they more
oriented toward something
special, that they maybe
were more funny or whatever?
ZIA AHMED: Interesting.
So that's actually a
really good question.
Thank you for pointing that out.
What I've done in
the book was when
we had things hand
written in it,
so not only did I kind of scan
those and bring those over
and to replicate in here, but
there are plenty of drawings
as well.
A lot of people have drawn
little sketches of people,
things that somebody drew.
Once somebody drew
pictures of things
that they saw outside the
window as we were driving,
where we were at that time.
Somebody actually
drew emojis, and we've
got plenty of those things.
So I think, again,
that's a total range
of different people's
thoughts and where
they were at that moment.
WILLIAM: We have
"The Scream" as well,
if you're familiar with that--
ZIA AHMED: "The
Scream" is in there.
WILLIAM: --masterpiece.
The drawings are actually
some of the-- they're not only
the most eye-catching things,
because as you're flipping
through that's what
you see the most,
but I think that they
are some of the most
poignant and fascinating
messages in the book.
And it's incredible
how much you can
convey with just a
few lines on a page
versus a whole paragraph.
ZIA AHMED: For sure.
And we're also very lucky
to be in San Francisco
where there is such a large
art community as well.
There are so many students.
I give rides to these too.
It's amazing to talk to
these people as well.
It's not just about
any particular things.
There are so many fascinating
different ideas and things
that the first thing that
comes to somebody's mind,
seeing that depicted
is kind of awesome.
AUDIENCE: So how
did you decide when
you were editing what
to put in the book
and what not to put in the book?
ZIA AHMED: That's
another good question,
and I was just thinking of
something that spoke to me,
something that either made
me understand something
about the person who was writing
it, know a little bit more
about them, learn something
about the city perhaps,
a little bit of
history, quite literally
anything that actually
spoke to me, apart
from the lyrics, the
quotes, and the cliches,
and we got tons of cliches.
I should just come out
with the book of cliches.
And there are so many.
WILLIAM: Like mine
probably, yeah.
ZIA AHMED: Shall we
talk about yours?
WILLIAM: Well,
after the questions,
yeah, we can dive into whatever
nonsense I put in there, yeah.
ZIA AHMED: But
that was the thing.
Whatever spoke to me is what
I was really looking for,
something that could
help understand something
about the person, the
moment they were in,
or something about the city.
But another really
interesting thing
that I do kind of
recommend or emphasize on
is that if you do read
the book, and if you
do, there are so many
things you'll see in this
that you will
definitely not have
heard about-- little places to
go, things to see, some ideas.
And whenever you do
come across that idea,
I always found it fascinating
to figure it out, Google
that-- you should totally
Google it-- and figure that out.
Perhaps put it on your list of
places to go next in the city.
Hit it up.
AUDIENCE: So you say you wrote
it for the next rider, right?
Does the reaction of
the next rider also
have an impact on what
you decided to publish?
ZIA AHMED: Oh, yeah, for sure.
That a great question.
That's the reason
why I kept doing it,
because of the fact that
it's so entertaining.
It's entertaining,
like doing this, just
seeing people's reactions,
just not only about, hey,
I have something in my glove
compartment from a stranger,
but also the things
that they were reading
in it, the presentation
of the diary,
just watching that was
really thrilling for me.
AUDIENCE: And no
one got offended?
ZIA AHMED: You know,
it's fascinating.
I think out of about
4,000 or 5,000 people,
I didn't offend
anybody from the book.
I'm sure there
are other reasons,
but not through the book.
and I think that it did
kind of-- after I qualified
the passenger-- if I
did share it with them,
they all cooperated very
nicely, and they let
something kind of interesting.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a question just kind
of going off of your point.
Have you ever
thought about, and I
know you were sort of
talking about this earlier,
have ever thought about asking
someone a direct question?
For example, you were
saying how lot of people
put in their favorite place
to go in San Francisco,
and you can discover a
lot of things that way.
Have you ever thought
about just like one day
you ask every passenger, hey,
where is your favorite place
to go when you need like alone
time in San Francisco or sort
of compiling
questions like that,
or do you like to keep it open
ended and like why or why not?
ZIA AHMED: No, I
think that's one
of the interesting future
side tracks that we can do,
but at this point I feel
like leaving it open as well
pressurizes a lot of people.
They're like, this
is so much pressure.
I'm just asking you
to write a few lines,
but that's an
interesting direction
that we might actually
take in the future.
I'm just not sure at this point.
And how long we can do that,
how quickly we can come out
with something,
show some results.
So perhaps that'll be
something we do later on.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that you kind of decide
whether or not you want to
offer your book to people.
Do you think that some
people are, by definition,
more interesting than others?
Do you feel like maybe you
missed out on something?
ZIA AHMED: You got me.
Yeah, I do think
that sometimes there
are some things that are--
I'm fascinated by technology,
I'm fascinated by the arts,
I'm fascinated by these things.
So if somebody mentions
some of these buzzwords,
then I'm definitely listening.
But the idea is
that this has also
been a learning phase for
me that I want everybody
to be part of it.
I look for as little
of a reason to ask them
to do this as possible,
but sometimes somebody
is just having a bad day and
you don't want to bother them,
and this is just a
reality of the situation.
And I don't mean to be intrusive
at all either, by the way.
Like I'm not just making
sure you do my thing.
So I'm trying to assess
first, understand, and then
hopefully get some valuable
feedback from the person.
AUDIENCE: Because I think
also that if someone's
having a bad day,
maybe that could
be the most impactful
if they look at it
or if they write something down.
ZIA AHMED: 100%.
Absolutely.
That's happened so many
times, like it's actually
not just the reaction
that I get from people,
but the way people's day
actually turns around.
It's like you can see
their faces light up,
and that actually
means a lot to me.
That's kind of why I'm
still doing this project,
and those are also
some of the reasons
why I feel that
continuing the project
is also kind of important,
because it does actually
help a lot of people.
They've called it
therapeutic, yeah,
that they got the
opportunity to do that.
So you're totally right.
AUDIENCE: What did
you leave behind?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
I want to see that.
WILLIAM: I have no--
I do not remember.
You asked me this.
You remember mine more or less.
I don't remember mine, and
someone else asked me what
I wrote, and I have no idea.
ZIA AHMED: It's in the book.
You have to buy it.
WILLIAM: It's not in the book.
I didn't make the cut.
If you could-- presumably it's
in one of those notebooks.
I don't know if you
remember even the page.
ZIA AHMED: That's
going to be a trick.
It's going to be a
tall order for sure--
WILLIAM: Yeah.
ZIA AHMED: --to actually
find that specific message
at this point.
AUDIENCE: It was
something beautiful.
ZIA AHMED: Wonderful.
It was great.
WILLIAM: It was very--
ZIA AHMED: But it
was interesting,
because I remember
when I got William,
the interesting
part was, there was
some-- which conference was it?
It was a Google-related thing?
WILLIAM: It was a mindfulness
conference near Yerba Buena.
ZIA AHMED: Exactly.
And he got a Lyft line, and
he was like five minutes late.
WILLIAM: And more often
than I care to admit, yes.
ZIA AHMED: But then
when he started
talking about this
mindfulness project and a lot
of interesting
things, that's kind
of exactly what I'm trying to
do with this project, where I'm
trying to get people out of
that and be a little bit more
present with the fact that
there's a guy sitting right
next to you.
Say hello, speak to him and
understand, like perhaps,
you know?
And obviously those are things
that I'm fascinated with,
and I like those things,
I appreciate them,
which is when I shared
the project with William.
And, again, we've been
in touch ever since.
He's also suggested
interesting directions,
and thank you once again
for setting this up.
It was super great.
WILLIAM: Well, thank
you Zia for coming.
AUDIENCE: We've got
one more question too.
WILLIAM: Oh, and we have a--
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just a question,
curious regarding
your process of doing this.
Do you read them
right after they
write them, or do you go home--
ZIA AHMED: No.
AUDIENCE: --and
get a glass wine,
or do you wait like a month?
ZIA AHMED: That's a good idea.
No, that's actually a
pretty good question.
So the way the
process actually works
is when the next
person-- so when
the person writes in the book,
they don't tell me what it is.
They quietly write it, they
put the pen back on the page,
they close it up,
they put it away.
And the next person who I ask to
read it, they read it out loud,
and that's when I even
here it for the first time.
So that anonymity allows people
to talk about really insightful
things, and not only from the
silly profanity and things
but also to lots of profound,
meaningful, personal things
that people have shared.
WILLIAM: Great.
Well, this is "Lyft Me
Up," available on Amazon
and in the trunk of Zia's Camry.
Thank you all for coming,
and the best of luck.
ZIA AHMED: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]